we're black everything here black
excellence you know what i mean so
lack
excellence
black excellence
[Music]
the concept of like black stories we're
still new in a sense you know what i
mean you think of like the dawn of
cinnamon our voices are just now
becoming more mainstream black
storytelling is everything like that
it's something that we need more of to
see representation to see our people to
see things that are recognizable to us
on screen
is so important for the new generation
that's coming up you know i think in the
past when you have non-black creators
telling black stories they sort of treat
our experience as a monolith one of the
main themes of the show is that the
black experience is not a monolith now
both carlton and will they are both
black they both come from very different
backgrounds and i think that having
black creatives on this project and
black creatives in general just you're
able to showcase the nuance in the black
experience if there aren't black stories
there is a
cycle that happens of us for getting who
we are and what we can do moments like
even black panther remind
black people
who we are you know
you know
the original fresh prince of bel-air
gave me hope
and inspiration
and it also it just it made me want to
dream as big as possible
i felt like i was the first prince of
bel air i was a fresh princess of camden
going to hollywood you know what i mean
i mean well first of all you know it was
will smith coming off of uh being a
rapper and diving into the show and and
just seeing the show address certain
issues and it was really cool that's
sort of how the show originally started
like will smith is young what do you
know about acting nothing but he knew
everything about the culture and fresh
prince bel-air was the first show that
really put hip-hop in everyone's living
room in a palatable way
in a funny way in a warm-hearted way so
how do you do that again you don't but
what you do do is you try to find
someone whose hand who's whose heartbeat
is still in the culture as it is now
and that is morgan cooper
you know morgan cooper he's
amazing he's
really influencing a lot of young
filmmakers when they
they see morgan and what he's
accomplished with this
trailer that he put together from that
trailer to to conception to this actual
coming to fruition
it's so inspiring you start assuming oh
he must have you know got certain
friends or or he's been doing this for a
long time maybe 10 something years and i
remember we're bowling last morgan his
age and he was like 29 i said 29
i'm 28.
and you're doing all of this you're the
producer you are the writer the story
you know what i'm saying and i'm like
wow it was inspirational for me because
you know especially being a black male
you know in the society it's like you
know my mom always say sometimes you got
to work twice as hard just to get to
that spot and it's true the importance
of having black creators behind the
scenes is just you speak a common
language to my right i have the gorgeous
lee jonte and to my left i have the
beautiful vicky thomas
and these women are so special to me
because so special
because they are the woman who
discovered me gave me this beautiful
opportunity to be with these beautiful
people with this beautiful family and i
can't thank them enough there's some
days where i just look at the writing
and i'm like damn like i would say that
i'll tell you something about matthew
cherry man this guy's the vote so
matthew
[Music]
he also did that too but he's so great
to shoot with you're dealing with black
excellence you're dealing with the shows
that really can go definitely between
comedy and the drama and just really
proud of morgan cooper you know he had
this vision
a few years back he shot this trailer
and it got everybody's attention and i
think that's what it is in 2022 and
beyond it's about authenticity you know
what i mean it's about us raising the
bar of our storytelling we've not even
touched like the one percent of the
millions of stories that we have but in
terms of this retelling there's so much
in there about elevating our culture
showing how diverse and nuanced we are
we want to see projects that represent
and reflect the world outside our window
and that's diversity inclusivity
um
and so we do that on this show you know
from the art that you see on the walls
so many great afro-american artists that
i'm getting to learn about you know as
they say it's like a celebration of of
the full spectrum of the of the the
black community now more than ever
people are calling for more
representation we're realizing that
there is more than one
version of a story to tell i think it's
important to tell black stories to
continue to have representation of all
shades of all elements of beauty of
seeing
black love of seeing black successful
business people all these things are to
remind
black people of their capability you
know and if you're always being told the
same narrative the same stereotypical
narrative then you really start to
believe that's really all there is to
being black when it comes to black
storytelling it's sort of funny because
you have a room full of a lot of black
riders it's what we do it's what we were
going to make you no matter what the
mandate was this is particularly a
family drama so what you have people
doing is pulling from their lives
pulling from their own families
pulling from their own upbringings and
all of that's going into the show
it's so helpful to bring a cohesive
vision when everyone brings the
experience that they have on their own
just to make it so fruitful and so
colorful
it's important to tell black stories
because they do well like it's not like
we don't kill it we do every time
what i liked about this show from my own
personal taste was here was a show about
a black family
and they weren't like part of a crime
syndicate it became a story about this
family and the relationships in the
family
and family secrets and black love
and that's been
sort of that's been very gratifying to
write
so often
as black creatives like there's the
feeling of being like on the outside
looking in you know and i just remember
you know working in kansas city and
seeing all these people that didn't look
like me in a space where i knew no one
but you know my mom always told me
growing up that imperfect action is
better than perfect inaction you see
what i'm saying so like you have to go
you can wait forever for the right
opportunity the right time or you can
get out there you know show up every
single day and just you know pull out
that camera and get a little bit better
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]